alors les séries il faudra appuyer il
faut rappeler ici c'est ça hein c'est ça
c'est ça exactement fait ça donnait
mariage bouder oui alors moi se faire un
petit régime banon va se faire une
bataille avec les cartes tu peut
mélanger c'est très simple celui qui a
la plus grosse carte et gagne celui qui
a la plus petite carte
il va y avoir cette assiette il ya
toujours quelque chose dont on va se
faire une bataille et écarte donc à
chaque fois on prendra celui qui gagnera
le droit de mettre un bouder dans
l'assiette pour que j'arrive dans la
figure de l'offre d'accueil ou pas ça
c'est les cartes
oui ça c'est la seule est un des invités
qui fait un mètre soixante tu me donnes
des cartes de 7,1 alors vas-y le mélange
mélange s'il faut trop bu pour bélanger
cette carte à quai
qu'est ce qu'on fait je veux dire une
gestion une carte c'est quoi la plus
petite la plus petite qui perd qui perd
écoutez bien parce que lui des fois ils
changent pas si mal c'est pas mal je
suis bon dans le film ça sent le valais
cet endroit oh la parade et ça marche
pas la mère si je regarde si ça
m'arrivait louer ça marche c'est bon
t'as perdu avec nous ça va tu as perdu
avec l'eau à tokyo
[Applaudissements]
je pose la question at il dit a perdu
avec l'eau ça veut dire là on va jouer
avec son père à mon avis je peux faire
il a bonne tournée le café quand même
non non non non non c'est bien la montre
la garcia luna si vous du mois de la
carte regarde attention batista 6,6 de
plus c'est pas mal là c'est au nom j'ai
commandé mon nom à la bataille abonnés
refait pas
[Applaudissements]
moi matin c'est fort allez vas-y à toi
[Musique]
berradi trois mois mais le 8e derrière
si tu prends la sienne a lancé le b
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
28 6 euros j'adore d'alex du cac à la
la sauce tomate n'ont évolué si c'est
pas grave a dit me remettre en confiance
en même temps la bad est d'accord 2-3
9,9 arrête maîtrise pas j'ai peur que ça
va aller mal et sautoirs et ben tiens
j'ai un mariage après
[Applaudissements]
après
[Musique]
toujours le bienvenu l'action prend un
blouson septembre match face aux usa
déjà je l'avais prirent